[Music]
in almost got away with it use it don't
forget to subscribe and leave it leave a
comment now you day you did it yeah tell
us that you subscribe submitted by
horchata voice oh that sounds good right
now me I love a man shot his girlfriend
in the head but she didn't find out for
a month what what with a pellet gun yeah
maybe she has a big-ass head oh maybe
she is she's just talking the whole time
and she she couldn't finish her sentence
and for a whole month and she found out
a long sentence girls can really talk
maybe that's how empty her brain is you
must be a girl no I can prove it let me
see I'll take my [ __ ] dick I don't
care go I can't get you guys to monetize
I thought so you have a [ __ ] like the
rest of us what's your Excuse now
patreon won't want your offer
why don't we all get naked no cuz you're
the one thing you're gonna take your
dick out but they know we're women women
women every woman is a woman
every woman all women are woman I don't
know about today's standards
alright so the two real dude this couple
from Atlanta they were in this girl's
car who is now 42 he is now 39 this
whole thing happened back in 2017 they
were having an argument when all of a
sudden you're not too far off dude I
take her back I'm sorry
you can talk I told you about for that
so all of a sudden the driver's
windshield or like the driver's window
burst and she passed out and so the
boyfriend told cops that she had hit a
tree and that's why the whole window
popped I don't know what's happening
with my speech fetter and the cops are
just like legit okay yeah
usually pop no yeah they were just like
the [ __ ] is not consistent with what
you're saying but anyway so immediately
once that happened he took her to his
mom's house and treated her because they
were telling her that like some glass
shards like cut her up and so that's
what they were treating after the gun
went off the charts that's probably why
the window shattered right for a whole
month she was suffering from severe
headaches memory loss and difficulty
communicating that's why she remember
cuz the memory loss oh man I'm gonna sue
the [ __ ] out of this guy power her not
until a friend of hers finally took her
to the hospital from there like a [ __ ]
is wrong she didn't even remember the
gun and went off I bet what if that
happened to you did that's why you
always like me I got that
imagine a monthly if friends like this
so how would I feel if you got shot a
man yeah no I really feel like her right
now in this video like what's happening
with my communication anyway so then she
went to the hospital that's when they
found out that she had a bullet in the
rear of her skull she is so lucky right
so the doctors couldn't remove the
bullet or else she could die ah where's
the bullet in the rear of her skull and
doesn't move wasn't she bleeding like
perfuse okay why did he try to kill her
and then nurse her back to health you
don't want to get in trouble yeah I mean
it his mom corroborated and [ __ ]
stitched her up exactly I'm waiting you
if that was your son you said you would
never write your son out but if you
think the bull of shooting his
girlfriend was like that or what if the
mom bought the tree story - yeah could
be she doesn't know what a bull I mean
we hit a tree and a bullet flew out of
the tree but the mom still kind of not
all there if she's like yeah it's okay
we're gonna stitch her up ourselves
rambo-style instead of going we should
take gonna make my mom believe anything
maybe she has a bullet the mom hope they
haven't found that yet
found it yeah I have a friend who had a
bullet in his head yeah like he got into
a fight at one of those counter strike
places with a now while they were
fighting over the video game like he
started waving a gun at him and he's
like holy [ __ ] so they ran outside and
then he got in the car I turned on the
car and then he started shooting at the
car and one of them bullets went through
you know like would he call it it's not
wear the glasses but the right where the
divider is where the glass in the metal
part went through their safety belts
yeah there's like a UH like the a pillar
the frame of the car right so like it
went through there and then it hit the
back of his head
he said you didn't even feel it cuz of
the adrenaline at the time and he had
his head so we called him bullet head
cuz he had a big being like this and
then there st. just grew over like it's
a big ball well yeah I mean they
couldn't take it out because the bullet
basically it comes in hot and then seems
like it was a 22 of so 22 is really
small so it has all these things to kind
of stop the velocity so like the
pressure of it and then so it if it was
a direct hit he would have died but all
these things kind of like in the way
slowed it down so by the time it got to
his head it cracked his skull and then
once the skull is cracked it kind of
filled it in so then if they pull it
like I keeps it together all the brain
juices fall out yeah girl now in the
story just keeps never already just
can't finish wrap it up well I guess you
never want to make baby number 2 huh
we've been making a half day we could
have clickbait it's alright exactly what
you guys are saying she does not
remember being shot at all she didn't
know she was shot she just remembers the
window shattering and she heard blacking
out so then that's when Mike cops issued
the funny thing is she doesn't even
realize there's a [ __ ] big knob on
the back of her head well who knows the
caliber they don't tell me but even at
22 you you wouldn't notice like if you
wouldn't notice a blister size something
on your head you're gonna [ __ ] notice
that well she
there was some kind of cut she doesn't
know what a bullet feels like it was
just a glass and same with the model ma
wouldn't know what a bullet wound looks
like so Oh like if it went through like
not the bullet stuff cuz it was stuck in
there mmm yeah so this dude he had a
previous he's a he's a felon sounds like
one because he has been convicted of
felony sexual battery back in 2010 the
shooting happened in 2017 would a piece
of garbage and he still gets girls and
like oh would you go to jail for an he's
a felony sexual battery can I get you a
drink so he has been sentenced to 25
years in prison
for several crimes including aggravated
assault with a deadly weapon and
possession of a firearm firearm by a
felon yeah
can't get these words out but yeah this
is what he looks like
nice picture bro like you didn't know
the [ __ ] picture was coming that's a
glamour shot could be photo
I'm guessing cuz it doesn't look like
it's not a buckshot dude you dressed up
for that [ __ ]
oh yeah DMV photos aren't blue in the
back yeah blue background anyway it's
like one two three taking it now you
wanted to look good for the camera I
love that dude cuz criminals are still
humans and they still want to look good
for the camera a lot of celebrity mug
shots cuz they smile because they know
that it'll get used in the press and if
they smile it doesn't really look like a
mug shot yeah pretty good take all the
pictures of Pablo Escobar you think the
biggest drug lord but he's doing like
the gayest [ __ ] like he's on a scooter
he's wearing like tank top with like
[ __ ] hairnet tape or like tank top
one like this with his buddies but if
you didn't know how gangster was you to
play all this guy's kind of like I feel
like that's how you know your real
gangster is when you're so comfortable
that everyone's afraid to make fun of
you yeah dude you could be on a tricycle
with those [ __ ] streamers on the side
yeah
like you will kill our entire feel like
it's like it's like when everyone gets
successful right what happens the first
thing you do is you buy all the things
that you didn't have when you're a child
right so this fool was like I've always
wanted to do the donkey rides you know
like when the circus came to town my
parents didn't take me to the donkey
rides so then like he [ __ ] gets dust
to do he gets to do the [ __ ] donkey
rides like a clown like hold him on the
donkey and [ __ ] Gabbar could have showed
up in a [ __ ] cheerleader outfit and
he's got that big horn thing and he's
like this yeah I need to even here's
like a guards it was like get that guy
get that [ __ ] guy I'm gangster that's
sure he was I guess do too yep like I
totally imagine Kim jong-un doing that
all day like black lingerie and black
pumps who'd I picture I picture him and
all of his like generals right like
there's a show that he puts on and it's
it's it's the k-pop show right so he
comes out and he does BTS things and
[ __ ] like he does their dances and if
anyone laughs they die dude I picture
he's wearing the golden the golden gown
from Beauty and the Beast and he's like
what don't look at my tits don't you
look at my [ __ ] tits and then he's
like why are you looking at my tits my
not sexy dude mine [ __ ] Kim is a
psychopath yeah that would be a great
show like don't look at my taste but
that you supposed to look at his taste
but then you shouldn't look well that's
a good heart oven show but then the the
whole it's like is remember that don't
laugh high school but it's like the
dictator's challenge to so there's a
dictator or a drug lord and if you can't
laugh or else.you that comes out like in
a maid apron yeah turns around and his
name is a butcher
that's like that Sandler movie where
Hitler's wearing a french maid costume
and he gets a pineapple shoved up his
ass every day in hell
Oh buddies bastards right is that it oh
no I thought it was a little Mickey or
some [ __ ] oh maybe you're right maybe
right yeah you're right you're right
you're right pineapple oh yeah yeah cuz
he's in hell and that's what he does
every day
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]